the Florida's softshell turtle spends  most of her life in water but has urgent  business on land she needs to get to a  delivery room and fast she makes it  across just in time and starts to dig  her eggs have to be laid on dry land and  her time has come but this she doesn't  need the attentions of the worst Midwife  in the world  the crows anxious to speed the process  along the turtle knows what the crows  after and she has a decision to make she  has to stop laying her eggs to save them  it's too late for the first unfortunate  egg  but the distraction gives her a chance  to head for shelter still carrying  dozens more  sometimes the good of the many outweighs  the good of the one  [Music]  you